[Music]
[Applause]
the all-action all-rounder is now all in
as captain take a bow ben stokes
he has the greatest respect for those
that have gone before him but he's very
much his own man
i've had to live with the tag of andrew
flintoff and
siri and both him since i was 18 but
i've always maintained that i'm never
trying to be andrew flintoff or sir in
both them i'm ben stokes
and he brings a wealth of experience to
the job on and off the pitch
from standing trial over a street brawl
in bristol and being cleared of all
charges
to a man of the match performance to win
the world cup final just two years later
and last year he stepped away completely
from cricket
citing a need to protect his mental
health there's always a negative um
feeling around you know mental health um
but i took my break i
um
went and spoke with people went and
spoke with someone and i will continue
to do that um but i see it as you know a
positive that me being in this role now
having gone through what you know i went
through last summer and even before that
that i've got a
um
huge amount of experience in what the
game and what life can throw at you the
greatest gymnast of all time simone
biles also checked out of competition at
the olympic games in tokyo last year to
protect her mental health
both she and stokes are indicators of a
significant change in elite level sport
actually
mental toughness is saying
i'm not going to do that regardless of
how many people expect me to do that and
have the strength to withdraw
get the help support care or time that
that person needs
and later return stronger and more
successful
ben stokes replaces his good friend joe
root who knew it was time for a change
after two dismal overseas tours
the ashes became embarrassing
stokes though was already a leader in
this england team and now steps up
ready and stronger due to everything
he's been through
tom parmenter sky news